the front of their bakery is still
intact
but otherwise zoe and panagiotis
chalesti lost everything in the fire
they've managed to clean up a bit
but they still have no idea what the
future holds
indeed they're almost as uncertain as
they were in august when we first met
them
many of the northern parts of the island
of evia were still on fire and rescue
operations were underway
the locals had never seen such an
inferno
and today they feel abandoned
we still haven't received any help
the state has given us nothing
all the equipment burned and the
building was damaged an engineer has
estimated damages worth 38 000 euros
luckily the flames stopped at the
village
but now the locals are worried that
other disasters loom
yeah
for example floods and landslides due to
heavy rain
after all the forests around us have all
burnt down
some people are already arming
themselves with sacks of sand and metal
barriers to survive the winter
this is a new worry
at least the authorities are trying to
create makeshift barriers to protect
against landslides
using the trees that survived
a third of the island's entire forest
burned down
over fifty thousand hectares
angeles jogansas earns his living from
the forest more precisely from the resin
of pine trees
the viscous sticky liquid is used to
make various products including paints
plastics medicine and cosmetics
evia accounted for 80 percent of the
pine resin produced in greece
it is sickening to see this beautiful
landscape all charred
many of my colleagues say
it would have been better if our houses
had burned down rather than the forest
experts estimate that it will take about
30 years until the forests are restored
knows that climate change is partly
responsible for the devastation he does
not have much faith in the government's
environment policies and plans for
renewables
prepositioning
just because some people want to make
money
greek prime minister kiriakos mitsutakis
announced in november that he would
invest massively to make greece climate
neutral
base of installed the goal is to have 55
fewer co2 emissions by 2030
even researchers at the academy of
athens say that this is a very ambitious
goal
however they also say that it will be
terrible if nothing is done
then
greece
would
be
much warmer with
even more frequent
extreme events
the cost of which would exceed
at the end of the century
700 billion
a monstrous sun that greece could barely
afford
that's why it's urgent
says zoe schalastie back in evie
something has to happen fast
there are these climate change
conferences but i think we have to start
with the young generation
children should learn about nature and
the environment from as young as
possible
and learn how to protect them
for now however the inhabitants of evia
still have to deal with the impact of
the fire
while at the same time preparing for any
future man-made catastrophes